wow
it feels like we're in the same room
yeah it feels like the future
the idea
is that instead of actually instead of
our avatars being cartoony
um and instead of actually transmitting
a video what it does is we've sort of
scanned ourselves and a lot of different
expressions and we've built a computer
model of sort of each of our faces and
and bodies and the different Expressions
that we make and collapse that into a
Kodak that then when you have the
headset on your head it sees your face
it sees your expression and it can
basically send an encoded version of
what you're supposed to look like over
the wire so so in addition to being
photorealistic it's also actually much
more bandwidth efficient than
transmitting a full video or especially
a 3D immersive video of a whole scene
like this